[Music]  where were ant-man and the wasps  did you see the Bunsen where was tip  check this question no I mean really I  have no idea  I mean I don't remember being asked to  be in their movie just saying maybe they  were on their way but they went  subatomic maybe they were there but they  were pretty tiny and there were  definitely semantics of a condor so  maybe there are in the same places  Hawkeye Kimura saw spider-man I was  really looking forward to meeting the  wasp yeah no not that we're  I just have one question  when cap needed help if I'd asked you  would you have come I guess we'll never  know but if you had you'd have never  been caught  [Music]  I do some dumb things and the people I  love the most they pay the price thanks  to you we had to run  we're still running let's go  [Music]  maybe you just need someone watching  your back  like a partner  hold on you gave her wings and blasters  so I take it you didn't have that tech  available for me no I did  you  you